news daily from science mission research
team shows that epigenetic marks that is
methyl groups on DNA present in mines
before pregnancy disappears after
pregnancy when the same sites were
examined a year after pregnancy they
remained unoccupied by methyl groups in
the second pregnancy the cells respond
more rapidly indicating long-term memory
in these cells next we such a show that
a histone demethylase protein that is
jmj d1a has a dual role in addition to
demethylation when it gets
phosphorylated during eid energy
stimulation it interacts with the
transcriptional factors and modulates
thermogenesis in brown adipose fat by
activating genes next researchers
developed a new mobile phone microscope
that uses video called sense scope to
detect motion and quantify infection by
parasitic worms in a drop of blood new
technology could be used in the fields
of Africa where the disease is prevalent
for more details visit us at
www.sentinelsource.com/site/forms/subscription